hello boys and girls Mogwai and gremlins
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show if
you're looking for perhaps some type of
highbrow intellectual long-form
conversation you might want to go to tim
blog for such podcast for one of my
other long-form it always Dan cell is
short dude come on hold on Kevin I
haven't introduced you yet but for those
of you who enjoy the the random
helter-skelter is that a right word yeah
I think it is nature well I'm gonna run
with it of the random show which we
haven't had an episode of for a very
very long time and it's a conversation
between yours truly and my good friend
Kevin Rose guest number one on the Tim
Ferriss show that's true
you were guest number one the very first
episode of the Tim Ferriss show and
actually that's a my LinkedIn bio now
that's my claim to fame it's in your
Google+ bio and we have not done a
random show for a long time but I'll let
you do if you want to do an introduction
of the ring I don't think I don't think
we need we don't even know what episode
Ron liked it for those that view they
have heard the random show before I
think we've done probably if I had to
guess I'd say maybe 25 episodes
something like that 25 yes unlike
episodes so weird 27 let's call it
episode 27 and Kevin for people who
don't know you what's your story what
would you like people to know about you
what's this obsession the speaker bio
version of Kevin Rose I don't even know
these days no seriously I would say that
I've been a longtime internet
entrepreneur I probably am best known
for creating these social news website
dig back in 2004 that grew to become a
pretty big entity for a number of years
and then I was at Google as an investor
and now I'm at true ventures as an
investor Tim you and I probably Co
invested and maybe a dozen or so angel
deals yeah at least Facebook together I
think Twitter together Twitter together
Blue Bottle coffee yeah yeah a bunch of
them sidenote you remember how ridiculed
we all were when the consort
of techies and non-techies invested in
Blue Bottle coffee do you know how much
[ __ ] we got on the internet for though
yeah absolutely they're like why would
blue bottle need to raise money and but
it's done okay and it had a great exit
here just about a month ago it has done
all right
it was a blow it was a majority stake
acquisition by Nestle for 700 million or
so so it worked out yeah so you've done
very well as an investor you are
obsessed with many things Japanese yeah
you have a new obsession it seems every
few weeks and do you have anything new
to add actually you know what is death I
want to hear about the fast mimicking
diet because this yeah thing I thought I
I would have put money on you never
sticking with the fast moving diet and
maybe you can explain for people what
that yes but you've actually now done a
number of scheduled five-day yeah that's
great that's five-day FMD so I'll start
back by saying that probably the reason
why Tim you and I are friends I met you
when you were launching your first book
on your boat party that you did you rent
it as a warship the San Francisco Bay
and the SS Jeremiah where they recorded
a lot of the boiler room audio for the
James Cameron movie Titanic Oh crazy
in fact mm-hmm it's awesome but yeah
well I we hit it off because we both
love all kinds of this idea of lifelong
learning I think has been a theme that
you and I both enjoy and you know I've
certainly got really into biohacking
in the last couple years I've watched
from afar you poke and prod yourself and
squirt all kinds of different juices out
of your elbow you know I need this
requires a little bit of explanation so
just this is so gross all right but now
I have to explain it so I had a botched
PRP injection which is platelet-rich
plasma injection in my right elbow and
people can look up PRP it actually has
some fantastic applications but there
was a botched injection which pushed
effectively subcutaneous bacteria into
the elbow capsule itself and it turned
into this horrible infection that
required a bright mint and surgery and
so on
but Kevin being the good friend that he
is came to visit me in the ER when I was
having the sure if you'd called synovial
fluid the infection flu is the pus
drained out of your faucets rained out
of my elbow with this gigantic syringe
and being the mature adult that I am I
thought it would be funny to take this
turkey baster worth of elbow fluid out
of the-- the sharps container and squirt
it in that kevin who was in the room I'm
not proud of it but I don't regret it
either
see ya you've seen me do a lot and make
a lot of short-term decisions that
haven't turned out very well in the
world yeah of biohacking it's always
entertaining though gotta say a lot of
fun doing stupid [ __ ] together
but yeah speaking of well probably not
that dumb these days but fasting so I
got into fasting here probably about
three years ago to have three years ago
I started the fasting at zero which is a
free fasting tracker and so that has
really kind of blown up and taken off
but then I started hearing about the
research from adult ER doctor Valter
Longo and so we actually was from a
friend of mine you know Mike Mazur a
mutual friend of ours yeah and Mike was
diagnosed with stage four cancer
he went into chemotherapy treatment and
he was one of the guys that said I'm
just not gonna you know just take what
they give me but I'm gonna go out and do
my own research and see what else I can
be doing to help fight this and beat
this down and one of the things that
came up was this idea of doing these
five-day FM DS and the FM d stands for
fasting mimetic diet and the idea is
that compliance of doing a standard 5
day fast is relatively low because it's
an extremely difficult thing to do it
Tim have you ever done a 5-day
water-only fast
have you tried yeah I've done 5 7 and 10
day okay
so I've done a 5 day water only and I
will tell you it is absolutely brutal I
don't know what your experience was but
like I had a really difficult time
sleeping
yeah yeah there's a I believe it's a
cholinergic effect that leads you to
have rapid heartbeat quite often yes
when you were trying to sleep it's not
pleasant so you'll be exhausted and
you'll lay down in bed and you're you'll
feel like you just ran a hundred meter
sprint in terms of harpy it it's very
very very unpleasant it's kind of scary
you like and I get those I'm also one of
those people that get those I get those
little or early heartbeats you know
where you like feel like your your heart
like kind of skip a beat a little bit
they're completely benign and I've had
it looked at and and everything's fine
but I get those every once a while and
those are those come more frequently
when I'm in a fasted state so long story
short Mike does his five-day fast he
beats back cancer he's in full remission
which is awesome but the idea with the
the five-day fast is had and I interrupt
to one more yeah the and I think this I
don't think Mike would mind this but I
remember you and I when we were talking
about this and he did he do five or
three I can't recall sorry you're right
he did the rate he did three but just
just for those who are curious so I've
had conversations with Dominic
D'Agostino before on this podcast very
well published researcher and I was
first introduced to the possibility that
fasting prior to chemotherapy I believe
and radiation could be either has the
potential to increase the resilience of
normal cells while increasing the
susceptibility or weakness of cancer
cells to facilitate this type of
treatment but also to decrease the side
effects that are commonly experienced
and so Mike to my understanding would do
say a three-day fast before a session
and while the other people in his cohort
were laid out on the on the couch or in
bed the next day he'd be running a 10
mile training run right which is just
insane
which is nuts yeah and so he originally
when he got turned on to this research
by doctor Longo is he showed me this
YouTube video where they were giving
rats chemotherapy and the one the rats
that were fasted were just like running
around the cage it looked like normal
healthy rats and the ones that didn't
fast were just like you said like on
their side all beat up and in a horrible
state and that's
exactly what Mike experienced and yet
the idea is that on the making the
chemotherapy more effective is that you
know you're depriving yourself of the
cancer cells of some nutrients certainly
sugar less glucose and it makes them
more susceptible to the chemotherapy
treatment so the chemotherapy is that
much more effective so you know
obviously we can't say for certain
whether that's will put him into
remission but he's really happy that it
did work and he is in remission and the
evidence looks pretty compelling in
humans and so they're also extending
this whole protocol to healthy
individuals as a way to potentially
prevent cancer from even forming in the
first place so I was turned on to dr.
Valter Longo 'he's new book the
longevity diet and i had him on my
podcast have you seen this book yet i
have seen that yeah i haven't read it
but i have seen it yeah it's pretty
awesome so that there's a whole chapter
on his f md protocol and what you need
to do to do these five-day fast and so i
guess getting into what it actually is
so how it differs from a water only fast
is that you do have calories so you have
around 700 or so calories per day some
people say that sounds like a lot some
people say it sounds like a little it's
actually not that much food it's like a
handful of small soups and some crackers
and you know the first day it's not so
bad you're like oh I can do this like
some crackers in a little bit soup and
then day two and day three and you're
like oh my god I'm dying right but it's
not nearly as bad as water only but the
the idea is that you eat just enough
food to still get into this fasted state
so all of your inflammation markers all
the things that the different markers
are looking at in your blood they look
just like you're you're doing a water
only fast but with a minimal amount of
food so you have a little bit of not as
much hunger and a little bit more energy
and so the compliance is much higher
were you tracking when you do these FM
DS have you tracked your ketone levels
at all do you get into ketosis or does
the small amount of carbohydrate and so
on that you're consuming keep you out of
ketosis I get a mild I would say I get
around point five or so millimolar z' so
it's like a very I'm on the edge right
which is kind of brood
because you're kinda in the keto flu
symptom area and so you're not folding
into ketosis well this is really
interesting because so a TIA
Peter Tia who you got on the show a few
times he's my doctor and I know you work
with him as well and we've kind of like
played around with this this protocol in
that a TIA has put together an FMD diet
that is a lot more ketogenic friendly so
a lot heavier on the fats and a lot less
on the refined carbohydrates so for
example when you're doing Longo's
version of this diet and he actually has
a nonprofit called prolong so you'd
actually just order this kit so I get a
kid in the mail that house all the
prepackaged food if you're watching the
video version of this this is what it
looks like here has happened to have one
of this it's like day five or yeah day
five what do they do what does the
nonprofit do with the money that they
get because it looks very into research
it goes back into research that's right
and in Longo doesn't receive any of the
in any of the money at all he doesn't
take a salary and so you know this is
meant for people that want to create a
little etaf eg a little cell death
generate new stem cells which has proven
actually happens via this five day
method and so the thing that hooked me
though is I have had and elevated
cholesterol on my whole father's side of
the family and that's turned into heart
disease with my dad and him passing away
from a heart attack my grandpa passed
away from a heart attack my grandma on
my dad's side passed away from a heart
attack so like it's it's running deep
and it's a little bit scary you know now
that I'm 40 I've got these pretty bad
numbers so so much so that Tia has put
me on Crestor which is you know knocking
back the bad cholesterol with a statin
but obviously I'd preferred not to be on
a statin anyway long story short I
decided to because of his book the
longevity diet I was reading through it
and he said that he was seeing people
that did the five day fast they were
improving their cholesterol numbers and
they were getting more good cholesterol
unless bad cholesterol so I was like oh
that sounds interesting I might as well
give this a shot but to give it a proper
shot you're supposed to do and I talked
too long ago about this but three
back-to-back five-day fasts of the over
three months and then once a quarter
okay so you do you there's like a
loading phase of fast that's right you
do whatever the first week of each month
for three months right and the king of
fasting is a good right and then you do
maintenance once a quarter thereafter
that's right okay yeah so I did the
first five day fast three months ago had
my blood work drawn drawn pre and post
you know small minor improvements ii
fast same thing and then by the third we
actually saw a dramatic drop on a few
different fronts cholesterol wise and a
TIA
was like when he called me up my cuz we
do these like little you know calls to
go over my blood work and he was like
Kevin you're gonna you're gonna live to
90 if you you could keep this out this
is amazing so he was shocked and he was
blown away and so we're pretty happy
with the results we'll see how long they
they stick and this is no dietary
changes this is just I mean granted
there's a dietary change during those
five days but no like long term I'm
still kind of sticking to the same diet
that I've always been been sticking to I
like that he was so specific with 90
that's lower than I would have expected
so they must be always with you must be
all the meth that you're doing that's
gonna kill you yeah I mean I still do a
dose of meth over every now and then but
now I actually speak in math dude I just
did some l-theanine for the first time
today
yeah have you tried this with coffee it
is very interesting stuff to be sure my
god dude I'd never tried it before
I took a pill of it it took 200
milligrams this morning and I was out
with with a mutual friend Tony Conrad we
met for coffee and I gave him a pill too
good and we were like cracked out for
like three hours man yeah so this
observing of the biohacking is a mutual
arrangement that Kevin and I have it's
not just him watching me squirting fluid
out of my elbow I also observe things
that you do now on the on the FMD though
just to return to that for a second you
mentioned in passing that a TIA head
looked at the possibility of doing a
lower carbohydrate higher fat he
actually has a protocol for that yeah
I'm sure he'd give you the PDF if you if
you asked for the podcast notes have you
tried it I did yeah I did that for the
second one and it was I liked it
actually I just happened to buy a 3-pack
of the pro long kit so I wanted to go
through them and use them because
they're not cheap and so I just use that
for the last one but I like it Tia's and
that it's a little bit more work
obviously because you're preparing your
own food but it's largely like his is
different in that with Pro lon you get
these little tiny snacks throughout the
entire day with his it's one meal a day
and it's a it's just a salad it's like
greens and like you know three
tablespoons or four tablespoons of olive
oil and like six olives and you know
like some sunflower seeds I think it's
not it's not a whole lot but it
certainly is is gives you it's not as
refined and so you I saw my ketone
levels go up on his vs. and I think I
had certainly more energy on his versus
the prolong got it well ping Peter about
that it makes sense that you would on
multiple levels that you would have
higher ketone levels and for people who
are wondering how one would measure
ketone levels I think you and I still
use the same device as the precision
extra x-tra by Abbott Labs which does a
sufficient job in measuring something
called BHB beta-hydroxybutyrate in the
blood for a for a number of different
reasons this is a much more precise and
accurate well let's just call it precise
but consistently precise maybe it's
accurate maybe it isn't a method of
measuring ketones or whether the degree
to which you're in ketosis then P sticks
because as your body becomes or if
you're already very efficient at using
ketone bodies you could show a false
negative where you pee on this on the
stick it tells you you're not in ketosis
when in fact you are so the right but
the blood is just more accurate well I'm
glad you're gonna live to 90 that makes
me happy yeah I mean it was it was a
pretty cool experiment and certainly for
someone that has heart disease running
their family I'm gonna keep it up I'm
gonna I'm gonna do another blood draw
here next week to see where my levels
are at and then try and do this
quarterly that's and hopefully if we can
get it down to where I won't be using
statins any longer that'd be great
the last
we did a random show it was a very very
long time ago I I believe it was at
least before you had a little monkey in
your house yes a reason many reasons of
course to stick around but now a very
compelling new reason so what is it how
would you describe since certainly I
have no kids that I'm aware of at this
point that's a good disclaimer there
yeah just you know that I don't have
kids asterisks that I know of what have
been the biggest changes that you've
felt were observed in yourself or
otherwise how you view the world
anything like that now that you have a
kid and what is your kid's name I know
you yeah Zelda she's four months old and
she's named up to the video game because
one of the first things that my wife and
I bonded on very early on in our
relationship was our love for the game
Zelda and actually the new Zelda game
allows you to track your hours played it
actually shows it in like the little
settings menu and so Daria has over 200
hours played of the latest Zelda so
she's she's hardcore she played a lot
during her pregnancy he's a true
believer and when we were in Japan a
long time ago Daria was using some type
of emulator I don't know what what
device it was on exactly but she was
playing Zelda
on all the trains when we were sitting
down and chilling that's what yeah like
the original yeah Josh Cooke was -
that's right yeah that's it's fun to
play the original ones with those
old-school emulators but yeah so in
terms of her I mean it's it's hard for I
think a guy in that when you first have
your first child it's it's like there's
not a whole lot to do there's just like
a lot of crying and so it's you know I
tried to help out where I can but it's
really like you know on the hip of mom
she was for the first you know several
weeks and just there's a lot of getting
used to new things and then now it's
just it's just amazing dude you walk
into a room and she lights up when she
sees me for the first time she smiles
and giggles and you know it kind of
changes the way that I want to approach
life in terms of what things are
important and trying to make
more time to be a good father and so for
someone like myself and that has so many
varying interests in and certainly can
get sucked into new things pretty easily
I've been trying to be a little bit more
thoughtful about where I where and when
I spend my energy so that I can kind of
dial back you know so I've spent a good
portion of this year trying to live a
little bit more minimalist lifestyle
what are some of the steps that you've
taken to do that well one of the things
I feel like you and I have had this
conversation every year since we already
met but now you actually have a gigantic
incentive to follow through every time
Tim I get together it's just like oh man
I've got too many investments I'm doing
this there's too many things going on
and I got it's too my time here and
we're always like more or less
complaining to each other other just
like just taking on too many things even
it's so ridiculous so I just been trying
to implement a few rules so one of the
things I did starting January 1st was to
throw away or donate something every
single day and so I have forced myself
to go in and so for example a few days
ago I went in and I just like picked out
all the clothes that I haven't touched
in a year and I took them down the
street like at a half a block away as a
donation place and I donated anything
that I hadn't worn in a year and it
really thins out your closet and I've
been designing it was that easy for you
to do or yeah absolutely
it was there was no resistance you are
like but that's the sweater that my aunt
Edie Janie gave me and now I mean I that
little lady you had in your podcast that
wrote that book on reading called Marie
Kondo
yes well technically ma ta con those how
they would say in Japanese but Marie
Kondo yeah Marie Kondo yeah she's
awesome so I listened about her
audiobook and one of the things that she
says in her audiobook is that the way
that you can depart with something is to
realize that it is already taught you
its lesson and that lesson may be that
it wasn't for you right so like if
have it hanging in your closet you look
at you're like oh but I someday I might
know the lesson is that it spent its
time with you it wasn't for you and it
should go to a good home or can be
appreciated by someone else and so my
lesson is not to buy it again and and
and so I took that and I've applied that
to thinning out pretty much everything
in my life and so every single day and I
think that a lot of people there's like
this analysis paralysis thing where you
think about cleaning out the garage or
you think about doing this massive
overhaul in your life and you're like oh
you know it's the weekend I got to do
this and there's always something that
jumps in front of it in terms of
priorities for me it's like I find that
if I just say ok one thing a day like at
the end of the year I'm gonna I may not
be to my goal but after five years there
certainly will you know it's not like I
have that much stuff but just really
saying do I need this in my life and is
it bringing joy to my life I think is
such a good forcing function to like get
rid of a lot of stuff and everything
that you get rid of is actually less of
a mental load on you there was this old
tea master that I met one time and Tim
and I've done some crazy travels all
throughout China in in tea lands but
there was this there was this one guy I
met oh the stories we could tell yeah
seriously we've done some crazy stuff in
the middle of the Yunnan Province
nothing sexual so uh long story short
the one thing that this tea master
showed me is he pulled out of his pocket
one key and he showed me the one key and
he goes Kevin do you know what this is
and as I guess it's a key you know yeah
it's the key to my house like it this is
this is my one key he's like I've worked
my entire life to have one key because
we can all have multiple keys you know
you meaning like the things you purchase
whether you have a key to your boat or
your spare garage or another you know a
motorcycle or whatever it may be there's
things in your life that you accumulate
and in the least amount of burden and
the most happiness you can get is like
having less stuff to worry about and so
that I find that to be really true and
so
that's what I've been trying to focus on
is is just having less and being happy
with a very handful of high quality
things I also want to mention that it's
possible to read a book like Murray
condos book which I can never remember
the title of because I want to say it's
like the magic art of Japanese tidying
up and it's like no it's something close
it's like the art of the joy of magic
cleaning up I can never remember the
exact phrasing I don't know why but in
any case that cult following with her
book leads some readers to think it's in
all or nothing
take it or leave it approach see you on
the other hand have philosophically
found bits and pieces of that book that
are very useful to you but our teacher
tactically actually doing the opposite
of what she recommends but it works for
you so she recommends doing this like
once in a lifetime tidying super bowl
basically we break out two or three days
of your life and that's what you do and
then the rest is maintenance it's kind
of like the Fed the fast mimicking diet
of Japanese tidying okay you have yeah
loading phase and I've had this book I
actually am looking at it on my
bookshelf right now for like two years
and I'm just like man I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it then I'm like two to
three days I look at my calendar I'm
like no I'm not gonna do it I'm just not
gonna do it so I like the idea
tactically of one at a time one per day
and also what's what's help me because I
do I have actually been since I moved to
Austin not too long ago it's been a
great opportunity after boxing
everything up it's like okay do I really
want to unbox all this stuff or do I
just want to donate right a lot of this
because it might be from a 1 to 10 scale
of value a 2 to me or maybe a 1 maybe a
3 but I could donate this very easily to
Goodwill or somewhere else to say a high
school gym that needs equipment which is
something I've done in the past and it's
an immediate 8 9 or 10 it's just a
brighter it's it's an it's a it's a nice
karmic chess move to donate and you see
ya think of not what you're losing but
also what you're giving to someone else
in that respect which I find really
helpful so you're giving away one item
per day the other thing too I will tell
you along those lines is that if there
is a purchase that I want to make that
is not just what I would consider to be
a you know a necessity like toilet paper
or whatever it may be
and it's something that is is is luxury
or not luxury but in the sense of like
you know it's gonna cost you over a
hundred dollars I don't necessarily need
it but I kind of want to try it you can
what I do is I say for later on Amazon
so you can add and say save for later
and you know set a reminder in your
calendar app for a week or two weeks
later and almost 90 percent the time I
end up not buying that thing I still
have one thing in there actually from
you it's a that not NAC knock yeah
should I buy that and it's not yet well
NAC so this is I should say with all of
this stuff that we're discussing because
it bears repeating we are not doctors
we don't play them on the internet so
everybody everybody should assume that
at least 50 percent of what we're saying
is complete [ __ ] nonsense and we are
just not sure which 50 percent it is so
work with a qualified professional
before you start taking or stopping any
type of medication or supplement the NAC
came to me initially because I was
looking at at it as a means to
accelerate recovery between workouts and
my understanding I might be getting this
wrong but is that it is a precursor to
glutathione which some people think of
as this master antioxidant or upstream
antioxidant that has a host of
beneficial effects and what I noticed in
taking the NAC is that I was over the
period of a week to 10 days perhaps
seven eight days into it that I was I
was more even keeled than typical than
then was typical
I felt very let the week had been very
smooth and I hadn't changed in anything
else that I could identify I'd been
and either meditating or not meditating
for a series of weeks there were a lot
of constants and when I went on to
PubMed and began to look at an acetal
cysteine and search for other terms like
depression or bipolar and so on there
were a number of search results that
popped up that seemed to indicate to me
that there was some promise in using NAC
to mitigate the amplitude of the ups and
downs that could be associated with say
bipolar and that that's the primary
reason that for for periods of time and
I cycle off of all of these things I've
become very fascinated by NAC which
quite nicely does have potentially
recovery benefits from an athletic
standpoint although most of my athletic
prowess has been focused on eating
oatmeal cookies recently so I can't
really claim that I'm doing a lot of
killer workouts I got rhabdo from eating
oatmeal cookies for you CrossFitters out
there and that's for you but the other
would be something you and I are both
familiar with it's with a which is low
dose lithium orotate a very very low
dose lithium orotate 5 milligrams which
you can find on Amazon and elsewhere and
there's a great New York Times article
which people can find very easily all
that is titled along the lines of maybe
we all just need a little bit of lithium
and it talks about the inverse
correlation of ground water
concentrations of lithium with I want to
say at least reported suicide homicide
manic depression and so on so those two
for me function in tandem or at least
appeal to me for very similar reasons
so the NAC should you use it or not I
think is a question of whether you feel
you need it and for me at least
currently I asked all the time like what
are your top 10 supplements that you're
using right now because people have this
impression after reading the 4-hour body
and so on that I'm just like I I walk
around with a drip IV bag in my arm and
have a thousand pills I'm taking four
times a day
I've certainly seen you in that boat no
you have seen me in that mode but
my mode right now is to really ensure
that I am using supplements as
supplements right that I'm not using
them to absolve me of the responsibility
to eat proper food for instance and it's
like look if you're drinking a lot and
you're like compulsively watching porn
and not exercising and like mainlining
Pixy Stix for your diet and you're like
wow I'm depressed maybe I should take 15
different supplements it's like no you
need to [ __ ] fix the rest of your
life right right and then see what your
baseline is because you're creating so
much static and noise and garbage inputs
that you don't even know what your
baseline is it's it's so disguised with
sort of the the trauma and confusion of
your inputs that you need to do you
track your baseline like do you log what
you will you consume and what you take I
log you know my baseline is this gonna
sound so primitive and it is but my
baseline is really how do I feel when I
wake up you know do I do I want to stay
in bed because I don't want to face the
day am i anxious are those my first
thoughts coming out of bed assuming that
I'm not checking my phone right because
I'm it's really my starting state out of
the gate of wake-sleep to wakefulness
and then at night how much trouble do I
have sleeping if any or do I fall asleep
easily how deep is my sleep and so for
deepness of sleep you could certainly
use something like an aura ring or an
accelerometer I mean there are different
means by which you could try to assess
the quality of your sleep but from me
really looking at how consistently I
feel good waking up and how long it
takes me to get up to say first or
second gear because it historically has
taken me a long time to go from park to
like second or third gear some people
wake up you might be one of these people
and they're like [ __ ] it world Here I am
ready to party That's not me it's like I
have a real slow build I think I'm in
between you and that I'm definitely not
ready to party the second I wake up I'm
after coffee have a cup of calm ready
party so I feel that way if for instance
I'm in ketosis past about two millimolar
z-- hmm I need less sleep so let's call
it six versus
eight hours and when I wake up I am
awake versus feeling groggy for an hour
two hour and a half which can be
remedied somewhat by the psychological
advantage of exercising in the morning
which is one thing I've been scheduling
to do more of per Jocko willing retired
Navy SEAL commander and all-around yeah
intense intense accomplished guy people
can find him to not blog for it's us
Jocko
first ever public interview so I'm
thrilled to have unleashed the giant
white gorilla on the internet and
baseline though to return to your
question is really something I try to
keep as simple as possible do I and have
I measured all those other things yes
but I think that whether it's with your
body or with a business or any number of
other things it's really easy to become
addicted to measuring things that don't
matter very much mm-hmm or we're still
measuring things that will distract you
from the things that do matter does that
make sense yeah yeah it totally makes
sense yeah I I've I've tried to kind of
pare it down to just the stuff I really
care about I just sent you a link in our
video chat to my dashboard for the
things I measure everyday cool
so for me you know I'm really concerned
about Mike glucose levels because they
are a tiny bit hell of it elevated so I
do
waking glucose bedtime glucose I do
whether I meditated that day or not I do
how many hours I fasted the night prior
I do how many drinks I've had and then I
do what type of workout whether I had
tea or coffee that day and then my food
but food not in terms of kind of a bike
by the calorie you know super anal kind
of breakdown but really just typing out
what I ate for that day
as a way to hold myself accountable and
just like look over the last few days at
a glance and see if I've been behaving
or not so I find that just the act of
writing it down makes me behave a little
bit better it does okay that was gonna
be my question is how does that actually
impact your behavior yeah you know I
this is a fascinating question I I've I
didn't experiment here about
three weeks ago with a group of five
friends and I asked them all I created
this spreadsheet that we all logged into
every single day and what you do is you
record the number of drinks you had the
night before and I was thinking about
turning this to into an app although I'm
not gonna do it but I was interested in
trying to create social pressure to
drink less now to drink more but to
drink less and the thing that I found
that was really interesting is that if
you drink over two drinks and a night
people have some shame in reporting that
and so they will miss report and so you
know if you went out and you had like
four or five drinks it's like I don't
want to be the guy they had the one
[ __ ] in the spreadsheet right exactly
so I changed it then
so the spreadsheet would only say two
plus and so that's the max you could go
and then people were a lot more like
open to being like yeah I had to plus
last night you know there were a lot
more at ease but it still created a
little bit of social pressure and
personal pressure if you looked at your
list you're like ooh there's been four
nights of - plus there I should probably
do a night without drinking right so my
idea was to create an app that would
allow you just to say up to 2 plus and
see all of your friends in the same
arena and then kind of hopefully
encourage you to be able to drink
socially but not take it too far yeah
this brings up all sorts of really
fascinating and frustrating
methodological questions in terms of
designing this type of reporting right
because I was thinking to myself as you
were saying this well if you had a
larger group say a group of 200 people
you would have one would expect you
would have more people in that group
reporting drinking 2 3 4 drinks on any
given night
right so the shame factor would be
decreased but if you decrease the shame
factor that also decrease the incentive
to actually behave right because you can
blend in to this right perceived
acceptability of being like well there
were the 10 other people out of 200
about 4 drinks last night that's totally
fine well the question is like how well
do you know the people 1 so how tight
are they out and you're like kind of
social connections and you're your peer
group and then also I think that there
is
when I like Brendan Mulligan I'll call
him out because he's a friend of ours he
works at Google he like never drinks
like he's like one drink one drink you
know like one drink every four days or
whatever and seeing him hit those
streaks of like zero drinks throw drinks
that was also a pretty powerful thing
and I'm saying I need to be more like
Brendan I need to dial it back so it
goes both ways yeah that's true I
suppose if you're seeing friends of
yours doing well we're doing well who
have demanding jobs demanding
relationships right you can't use that
as your excuse when you have the data
right in front of you showing right that
they're actually behaving so you you uh
you historically have been a nontrivial
drinker let's call it a looks like a
minor league all-star of booze
consumption I used to drink a lot more
to be honest you can see my spreadsheet
here so what has helped you most to
decrease the amount that you drink well
I think there is fear you know I've seen
a bunch of studies there was one that
was just published here a couple weeks
ago they said the number one the largest
study ever around dementia and alcohol
abuse and they're very closely linked
which is really frightening and I think
just you know wanting to live longer for
my daughter has been another one back to
the point that you had earlier about
what what has changed and just getting
older you know hangovers get happen at
two-and-a-half drinks these days right
so it's like why why roll the dice and
so for me it's it's finding two to get
your question around what have I done
differently there's a couple things one
I've kind of set aside time to learn at
night which i think is really important
and you really can't drink and learn at
the same time so although or remember
what you attempt to learn right exactly
and the second thing that has been
hugely though has been the sauna the
sauna has been massive because it is
like for drinks or three drinks just by
going and doing a 30-minute high intense
heat sauna session and you come home and
you sleep like a baby and you know if
you don't have a sauna that can also be
substituted with a really hot bath and
just finding ways to it's like that it's
always been about I'm with my wife I'm
sitting down and we're gonna crack open
a bottle of wine and I'll have a couple
glasses of wine it's never been like hey
let's go party those days are long gone
like you know a decade plus gone I've
know decades like a decade if we're out
traveling together Tim I'm gonna we're
gonna have fun right so the only times
you and I hang it's like when we're
traveling together so you can't like you
can't put that on me
that's true all right all right fair
enough for in different cities now I
will say for those people who are like
wait they can see each other we are
doing a very intimate
video chat on skype that you you will be
able to see on my youtube channel just
youtube.com forward slash Tim Ferriss
two hours two S's and Kevin is dressed
for success I will note he is I had a
partner meeting this morning so we
dressed up a little bit I appreciate it
I appreciate it so so I gave you that
look traveling's a bit of an exception
now how do you prevent yourself you like
you have traveled a lot in some cases
historically now that may change with
your daughter but how do you prevent
that from becoming the excuse to drink
that happens frequently does that make
sense because this happens in all sorts
of capacities right where people say
yeah oh you're traveling you should eat
pizza every night right I hear that I'm
like if I if I followed that rule I'll
be Jabba the Hutt because I'm I end up
travelling so much if I allowed myself
that out it would become a real problem
yeah yeah travelling is is difficult and
especially when it's in kind of a social
setting you know if you combine
traveling with social like you know I'll
be going to to Ted in a couple weeks and
I know that there's just gonna be a lot
of parties and a lot of events and a lot
of drinking so I think that's one of the
things that I need to work on is that I
have a hard time dealing with like large
groups of people that I don't know and
as a social lubricant alcohol is amazing
right so it's like what else can we do
and I think that someone was telling me
this that you know you never really
strengthen that muscle like if you're
you lean
the crutch of alcohol so you're never
going to become more comfortable with
new humans and new interactions and new
ways of like kind of breaking the ice if
you always just go to the booze right so
I think of it as like okay this is my
workout I'm going into and the other
thing I do is I so I got a couple little
hacks one is to show up a little bit
late so you then you skip a drink right
and it's funny how if you skip a drink
or two and you get there and people are
already a little hammered how
unattractive and unappealing drinking
them becomes because you looking at or
as like hey it's good to see you know
it's like a little bit sloppy and it's a
little and you look at that you're like
okay they're relaxed they're not gonna
like you don't remember what I said
anyway now that that hammer but you know
what I mean they're in a relaxed state
so I can be a little bit more jokey and
be myself and not have to worry about
being hammered gee so I think that
that's a big piece of it you know when
I'm at home you're gonna laugh at this
but on Amazon I went in I bought these
speaking of buying more things and
probably I'm gonna throw away any air
I bought these measuring cups that
measure out exactly one glass of wine
and so what I do there is like you know
a bottle of wine we all know is like
kind of like a half bottle wine is like
kind of two and a half maybe you know
it's it's it's up there and it's very
easy like like Daria will just like have
a little bit less than me and I'll say
okay well I'll just wait till it gets
halfway and then I'll stop you know to
try and but you're actually drinking
more than you think
so yeah plus with a wine glass if you
have a large wine glass you can drink
like a third of a bottle all right let's
talk about very easily right exactly so
what I do now is I bought this measuring
glass off of Amazon I fill that
perfectly poured in get my second glass
fill it perfectly and pour it in and so
that's all of my alcohol for the night
it stops me at two drinks and I really
take my time with it then you don't have
dinner I slowly sit but I look at it you
know I go sit down might watch a little
John Oliver or something and then just
like continue to sip on it and so that's
my way of locking and I know no more
past that it's prevents any hangovers
you know my doctor says it's pretty good
for you to have a glass or two a night
so and then also do telepathy
it is good for you I'll go this no but
then it's also just taking nights off
all together I think that's the other
big piece of it yeah yeah for sure good
for you man I love it now you you
mentioned one other thing well actually
a couple of other points cuz I've been
also cutting back on alcohol quite a bit
I still enjoy alcohol not gonna lie like
I do have booze on occasion I love
you're drunk like oh the drunk dials
yeah yeah you know I those are those are
fun so for those who don't know
occasionally I do these drunk dollops so
it's where I will the laziest podcast
format thought up I think to date
perhaps which is I have listeners fill
out a Google form with their contact
info and I set a time like a two hour
window where I'll call people via Skype
and drink start drinking at call one and
drink all the way through to say call 10
and get progressively more inebriated as
I answer questions so that that is fun I
did one about a week ago it was a good
time and then I thought you know I
should do another episode today and I
was like I just don't want to do two
nights of sipping tequila on skype and a
few things that have also helped me
number one is and this is not an excuse
everyone's gonna be comfortable using
but if I go to a party and they're like
hey man you're not drinking it what the
[ __ ] like yeah you should I'll be like
yeah I'm on a bunch of weird drugs like
I just actually I'm not really and just
supposed to take I'm not supposed to
drink alcohol right now which oh that
stops the conversation right there
that's brilliant yeah well it stops the
push right right and then it also starts
another conversation which is well what
kind of weird [ __ ] are you on and if you
at any given point I think it's fair to
say that I could answer in the
affirmative to argue on any weird [ __ ]
like I'm almost always doing something
odd I might not be a lot of stuff but
I'm probably trying something new and
that stops people cold if they're like
oh wow I mean it could be tylenol like
if you're taking acetaminophen in any
capacity people may not realize this but
some absurd percentage of emergency room
visits and
liver failures are associated with high
dose acetaminophen which is not that
much it's something like two or three
times the label allowable amount over 24
hours it's really a potent and
potentially dangerous drug so that's one
is like hey I'm actually on this I'm a
on a B and C or I'm on a bunch of weird
stuff at the moment and I'm just not
supposed to drink works really well in
second this is actually advice that
Richard Branson gave on this podcast is
having club soda with a dash of
cranberry juice or something like that
and yes using that as your default go to
and you know one thing that I do which
is gonna sound really odd and it is odd
but I have a superstition about hey
cheering right clinking glasses when I
don't have any alcohol my glass Oh
interesting is your tell this is this is
something well it's kind of a tell but
what I'll do is I will sometimes also go
up to the bar and I'll say just give me
a tiny splash like a like the equivalent
amount that would be in a thimble or
something like that and then I'll then
I'll cut myself off at that and that's
the amount that I allow myself that's
another approach that I take to cut back
on on the on the booze you mentioned
though that you've been trying to learn
at night and that the booze is not
conducive to learning at night what are
you trying to learn at night with types
of things and what's the format are you
reading well under 100 pages a night or
what is honestly have you heard of this
course area of course called learning
how to learn I have not who teach oh oh
so it's done by a couple professors and
I'm actually in the middle of that right
now
it was another kind of bio hacker
recommended to me apparently it's the
number one watched course on Coursera
right now and it's just been fascinating
how they dig into the science of
learning and like how you go in this
kind of like focused or diffuse mode and
how to really go in and concentrate on
something and when the optimal time is
to learn and it's all the science around
learning what is oh that oh sorry to
interrupt go ahead oh I'm just kidding
I'm just getting started with it so
that's that's what I've been diving into
and kind of spending my
nights watching those videos but it
talks about the importance of actually
getting away from your material it's
like getting really focused and setting
a timer for 25 minutes maximum going
really in-depth on the the the course
material and then backing away and kind
of going into this more relaxed mode
they're talking about how was it
Benjamin Franklin I camera who was that
used to hold a pair of keys in their
hand and they've kind of Salvador Dali
to this as well actually hold a pair of
keys in your hand you kind of just go
into this relaxed state thinking about
what you want to learn and to where you
almost fall asleep and when you drop the
keys out of your hand and it wakes you
up that's when you kind of go back and
then you realize you were successful at
getting that that relaxed and you'll
retain and become more creative and I
don't know it's just fascinating stuff
and so I'm just getting start with the
course it's free
very cool yeah the the intervals and the
duration intervals for learning along
with break periods is is something that
I've experimented a lot with as it
relates to language learning because
it's so measurable you can look at say
your recall of foreign vocabulary
assuming you're controlling for a few
different variables right so adjectives
are generally gonna be harder than nouns
for instance but if you are controlling
for that you can look at what your
retention is say 48 hours later for a
hundred words you attempted to learn in
one session versus two sessions versus
three sessions the different types of
breaks and I did that when I was looking
at a few different languages
specifically over 2004-2005 actually
I've never shown you these notes I have
text to edit documents with all of my
notes on language learning for about a
year year long period looking at all
this type of stuff and there were some
very clear patterns such as focusing on
the material right before bed with no
interruption so much like how it's
recommended by many names both you and I
know that you meditate first thing in
the morning before you brush your teeth
before you check your phone before
anything else when you have this tabula
rasa blank state of sorts focusing on
material that you want to
consolidate in memory and recall later
right before bed uh at least in my
experience dramatically improves recall
and then this is actually very important
not just doing that but when you wake up
before doing anything else which from
for me would override meditation doing a
recall exercise of some type I tend to
use flashcards to determine which if
stuck in which have not so those things
that have not since I'm looking at
language I would usually I would give
myself like a quarter of a second it
couldn't be delayed because in speech
you're not going to have the luxury of
sitting there paused for long periods of
time it would go back into the rotation
for review again throughout that day and
later that night but that's that is
proven really really helpful how about
exercise one of the things I mentioned
in this course is this idea of doing
cardiovascular exercise I believe it's
post learning something new and
apparently this science was saying that
it just sticks that much more I don't
have any numbers in front of me but it
was it was something along have you
heard anything about that so I have in
terms of spacing or I'm sorry that the
timing of exercise I I have less clarity
but there's an entire book called spark
that talks about the among other things
the role of exercise in education and
learning and would point to things like
BDNF the release of brain derived
neurotrophic factor which can be
elicited through different types of
exercise and you know part of me thinks
that when one says because these are the
easiest to study or very often the
easiest to study cardiovascular exercise
this is where it comes down to trying to
become literate with reading scientific
studies or understanding how things
typically work so as a couple of
baselines scientific studies usually use
volunteer populations known as students
and those students have 45-minute class
blocks or 60 minute class blocks so to
keep those students busy people are very
often disincentivized from using shorter
duration
a high-intensity training or something
like that weightlifting for instance
resistance training and if you want to
as an experiment or design something
that requires as little monitoring as
possible it's like all right stick them
on a stationary bike right if you have
people doing burpees or deadlifts like
you actually hate burpees yeah but you
need to pay attention right you need to
pay attention if people are lifting
weights and so on there are more safety
concerns so I think that and just to
point out perhaps the obvious that
weight lifting is actually one of the
most cardiovascular activities you could
possibly engage in but I won't digress
into that you can look at a book called
body by science for for all the details
and why that is the case but it would
make sense to me that exercise could
certainly play a role in increasing
cognitive function but one of the
questions that I ask myself all the time
when and this is a good question for
people to ask themselves when they see a
headline that makes a scientific claim
is what else could explain this like
what else might explain this so if
you're looking at cardiovascular
exercise right after some type of
cramming with material you could make
the argument that perhaps it's not the
exercise at all it's the fact that
they're going into a semi mindless or
meditative repet repetitive period where
they're they're able to their
subconscious somehow work on the
material right right well that's exactly
what this this course teaches is how to
get into those periods yeah 100%
yeah so the I have certainly seemed to
observe that exercise in some capacity
for me it's generally some type of
resistance training does have a positive
effect on on learning so yet another
reason to get off your ass which is
something I need to do more of i've
digressed fallen off the train a little
bit Kevin Rose I'll be honest but I
shall get back on the train oh yeah so
fortunately you know once you have a
recipe that works you have the
confidence that you can get back on that
that's the good news right with say the
fast moving diet not that you should use
that
body composition but fast men making
diet or intermittent fasting which a lot
of people use your apps euro for or slow
carb diet plus a handful of things like
kettlebell swings I just know this is
why I'm not stressed out about being off
the rails I kind of make make fun of
myself about it because it's like look
if if I just follow the prescription
like follow the algorithm for 3 to 4
weeks there's no magic involved yeah it
will work and I will have less like
muffin top to grab when I'm in the Sun
that will make me happy muffin top in
the sauna is the word you see that
little layer it's a little yeah well you
also have like the the glistening
Cinnabon effect because you're sweating
it's a really unattractive look yeah
it's not a good look one thing I did
want to talk about which I think would
be fun to chat about cuz we both done it
real quick is the Tony Robbins yeah yeah
let's talk about it for sure so yeah so
you recently had I've done two different
Tony Robbins events ubw unleash power
within which was my first event and then
more recently in December of this last
year date with destiny which is a longer
event oh did that I didn't know you did
David destiny like what I did so I've
done two events and some people have had
a bit of exposure to date with destiny
through the I am NOT your guru
documentary which was was co-produced in
fact by someone who's been on this
podcast Brian Koppelman really
accomplished filmmaker but what was your
experience like first Tony Robbins event
yeah I mean it was kind of crazy I've
thanks to you I got you know hooked up
with him and in went down and and got a
chance to meet him and hang out with
them I you know I think that Tony is
this is kind of he's proven himself now
that he's been doing this for so long
he's doing it for 40-plus years but I
think that in in the back of my mind I
kind of remember when I was a little kid
the kind of like audiotape version
infomercial version of Tony you know so
there's always the stigma in my mind
that was like oh is he trying to sell me
something what's going on here you know
and I also watch his documentary and I
was like well this guy's clearly
brilliant he takes this stuff very
seriously and you
truly breaking through to people and
helping people change their lives and so
it was like hey I'm gonna be in the Bay
Area you know you should come down I was
like okay that sounds awesome
took a buddy of mine that has a lot of
anxiety and he shall go unnamed but he
wanted to go and he was like heaven
let's do this and it's like okay let's
do it
so went down for the three-day event and
I thought it was great I got to tell you
it's you walk into it and I was in an
arena where there was you know 12,000
people and so there is a lot of people
there and everybody is coming there for
a different reason right so I was
sitting across from a guy that had lost
his legs and was a previously a drug
addict and I think he had some infection
his legs or something had to have both
amputated I was sitting next to someone
that she was running her own social
media business and just wanted to like
you know get better with her business
and improve her finances and she was
getting through a relationship that she
had just ended and you know so everyone
had something to kind of come in and
bring to the table of course we all do
if we're honest with ourselves everyone
has someone there's something they're
trying to work on and so you know I went
in there and day one was awesome I mean
Tony got out there and he spoke for like
I don't know 12 hours we were there yeah
he's a saint complete mutant yeah it's
unbelievable
I don't even know when he pees yeah I
have no idea when he uses the bathroom
or drinks water yeah just yeah
it's just a machine the guys but you
know I walked over the coals with him
and he he was like bring out some fresh
coals for Kevin and of course they put
like fresh he walk you actually walk
over coals at the end of the night
you've done this right I have yeah
did he bring out fresh coals for you I
can't recall if he brought out fresh
coals for me I think that might have
been the the VIP treatment that he
received it was a lot of fun and I think
that the biggest takeaway for me was
really a couple things one was
definitely this thing called the Wheel
of Life did you have to do that we feel
like your wheel I'm sure I did I'm sure
I did anything I should also point out
that for the attendees of these events
and I have a little bit more to say
about this but
the exercises that really and there are
very tactical prescriptive exercises but
that the exercises that change someone
else's trajectory and give them
extremely concrete next steps that have
an impact are very often completely
different exercises from those that
affect the person right next to you
means it's really something to behold
but tell us about the the wheeled life
yeah so the wheel of life was
interesting in that basically he gives
you these areas of your life and your to
rank them from zero to ten on how far
along and how kind of just happy you are
with those those areas so for example a
physical body right so for me I was like
I got to get myself a four and this let
me now I could be doing a lot better and
then there's emotions and meaning
another one is relationships
another one is time another one is your
career in your mission and life and then
there's finances and then the last one
is how you contribute like how you give
back how you celebrate and contribute
and so you go from from kind of 0 to 10
and you rank these out and you'll see my
wheel doesn't actually look like a wheel
it's like kind of lopsided but that's
why that's by design
by the time you you look at this it
gives you a clearer view of like okay I
really need to step out how I contribute
and give back and so that allowed me to
go really deep in my own personal life
and and say what does it mean to
contribute and give back for me and like
you know you and I have both done things
in terms of like going out and you know
charity water or the Tony Hawk
foundation and giving away money but
like just supporting a cause and in
writing a check I don't know how you
feel about this but for me it doesn't
really mean that I'm giving back I don't
really feel like I'm contributing yes
I'm giving like cash but I'm not
actually taking part in that process I'm
not actually really helping out like
anyone can write a check so what does it
mean for me to contribute and the thing
in the realization that I came to and
actually there's some really powerful
moments in this conference where they
turn out the lights and they
like make you revisit like certain times
in your childhood and all these things
and you know I felt myself kind of
tearing up because one of the things I
realized that I was not giving back any
in contributing in a meaningful way and
the thing that I came to and that I
realized is that my mother was verbally
abused by my father for many many many
years and you know definitely abusive
behavior never physically harmed her but
you know I would say that the mental
harm was is is better if not worse than
then some of the physical harm and and I
realized that I want to actually lean in
and help out women that have been abused
and that are currently in abusive
relationships and so a goal of mine over
the next couple years is finding the
best possible way to contribute back to
that not just in forms of another check
but actually how I can get involved and
whether it means helping them build
their products and build a better
website or mobile apps or any way that I
can enable and use my technology skills
to help with their business I think
would be something that would mean a lot
to me so that was that was a great
experience to have and I wouldn't have
that if it wasn't for Tony and I in and
that was just one of many things I got
out of the weekend so I would say that
you know he's a badass it was it was
pretty awesome
yeah he's a real master of his craft and
what I would say to folks who have a
certain image of Tony is that when you
go to an event like this I think the
right a way to approach it is to be
skeptical but not cynical and open to
trying all of the exercises he suggests
and that they're going to be components
that may not agree with you in the sense
that there's a lot of jumping around
there's a lot of music there's a lot of
noise for lack of a better word and a
lot of those elements made me
uncomfortable they're not things that I
would seek out oh my god I could not see
you dancing and jumping around right
right yeah it's just not my thing so but
the filter that I used going into it or
the lens through which I was looking at
it was it was made easier be
as one of my one of my very close
friends I've known since college who's
had multiple company exits is extremely
extremely accomplished and he goes to
unleash the power within every year as a
reset he's been 11 times maybe 12 now
he's been a date with destiny six times
and this and this guy is not a seminar
junkie he's not someone who avoids the
work and goes to listen to a
motivational speech so that he can feel
better on a sugar high for two days and
not take any next steps like this is not
that guy he is an operator so the fact
that he had been so many times really
led me to want to stick with the entire
event and I'm not gonna lie I had hard
points and then I mentioned this to you
and it may not be the exercise that had
a large impact on you but the Dickens
process that I ended up along with Tony
including in tools of Titan's one of my
more recent books because it had such a
big impact made the entire event and
easy like 10 to 100 X returned for me
that was the last day - that's right so
just that the 30 to 60-minute exercise
led me to dramatically improve my
relationship with my father to take
responsibility for certain things that I
had been telling myself were
unchangeable to really buckle down and
step into discomfort to make some
meaningful changes and it and those are
changes at least the power within I want
to say I went to now it's got to be
three to five years ago
those changes the ripple effects of
those changes that I made then are still
very tangible now and then date with
destiny very similar but to go into it
expecting that if you step into it and
accept some level of discomfort and
commit to trying everything this is just
my view that at least 50% you're going
to end up discarding probably 20% you're
gonna find really uncomfortable and
you're gonna dislike actively and then
like 10 to 25% you're gonna go holy [ __ ]
I can't believe how powerful that just
was and it's not a lot of hand wave
woowoo ambiguity these exercises are
really really really specific so you
don't have to accept Tony as your one
and only Savior you don't have to
believe that he is flawless because he
is not he's just like everyone else
he's imperfect creature trying to do the
best with the gifts and talents he's
developed but the guy knows his [ __ ] and
he actually he actually really cares and
as I've gotten to know him over the last
few years more and more so I've become
more impressed with him not less
impressed
and that is at least if one were
thinking of let's say ten day one of
these events and I have no zero vested
interest and sending anyone to these
events other than they've had a material
impact on my life and that's why I was I
was happy to see that you're going to
attend that they go in with an open mind
expecting that much like if you've read
any type of book you're not expecting
every line to be a life-changing piece
of gold you're hoping that net-net it's
going to be worth the time that you
invested yeah right and yeah that's been
my takeaway that it's absolutely been
worth the time invested yeah 100 percent
agree and I think that like you going
into this was a certainly a really
uncomfortable thing for me in terms of
when they first start the music and and
people come out on the stage and they
start dancing and like you can tell the
people that have been there before
because they immediately like jump out
of their seats and like start like kind
of rocking out and throwing their hands
there and I'm thinking to myself I hate
dancing I hate dancing I've never liked
dancing with anyone my wife or anyone I
always feel so awkward when I'm doing it
you know like I'm like a geek that likes
to like sit him from my computer at
night and so it's like then I thought
something another friend had told me
that had gone and said hey Kevin like
you just have to go with it like if you
want to get anything out of it you have
to realize that he's doing this by
design to put you into a certain state
right he wants to get to get you in the
into an optimal state and an optimal
that could mean like like wanting one
example of one thing that we did is we
took something that was very serious to
us like something
like a limiting belief that you had held
so seriously and you say it out loud in
a very joking and like laughing way and
everybody like 12,000 people are all
doing this at the same time and you're
like laughing and saying it and it's
kind of like breaking it down in your in
your mind and letting you know that you
don't have to take it so seriously and
you can joke about it have fun with it
because it's been forever since since
you know you've probably ever done that
in your life like you've the when was
the last time you were to able to take
something that you held so seriously and
so guarded and and and have a good time
with it and so he knows how to set up
these little traps for you that that
trick you into reframing things in your
mind and it really does change your
long-term perspective on things and yeah
I'm dude I'm a fan I would definitely go
back again I did the three-day event the
unleash the power within the same one as
you but yeah I had had fun with it so so
thanks for helping out with that Yemen
my pleasure
I I would suggest also that that's
that's Molly saying hello in the
background for those people who can hear
my dog barking but that is a is a point
of social proof and of course Tony is
fully aware of the sort of gravitas this
would bring but there are people for
instance Marc Benioff of Salesforce
which I think has more than ten billion
in annual revenue now who will
point-blank say that Salesforce would
probably not exist were it not for Tony
Robbins and still attends some of these
events he's right behind me at date with
destiny crazy
he's a big guy isn't he he and Tony are
very similar in size and then you have
Paul Tudor Jones you have some of the
most sophisticated traders and financial
minds who have worked with Tony for 10
to 20 years and that's on an ongoing
coaching basis because he does have very
discreet very tactical exercises and
tools that help you to find blind spots
and fully leverage the things that
you're good at and so on so it's it's
not easy it's not comfortable but
certainly I've been I've been very
benefited by the time that I've spent
considering these things and I'm biased
because in high school I read unlimited
power by Tony which had an impact
I then when I got out of college and had
my first job and I was commuting in my
piece-of-shit minivan this grid the
green machine which was just a complete
disaster a car but I was trapped on 101
in the Bay Area for people who know just
bumper-to-bumper in rush hour to and
from Mountain View this to San Jose to
work and I would listen to this used set
I couldn't afford the full set a new
copy so I had personal power too and
cassette tape and listened to that which
helped get me to the point where I
started my first company and so Tony's
made these appearances at very opportune
moments my life and you know he's not he
like I said I don't go to him for all
things I don't think that Tony has the
answer to everything
but with particular types of
self-imposed narratives and handicaps
that you have built yourself or walls
around certain types of thinking or
certain types of emotions that perhaps
served you very well in the past but no
longer serve you he is exceptionally
good at helping you work through all of
that yeah I just love that this whole
genre like the self-help genre is
becoming like it's not is frowned upon
as it used to be like I don't know if
you remember but probably you know 10 15
20 years ago like if you went to that
area of like the bookstore you were like
oh look at like who's in the self-help
section like they must there must be
something wrong with them
and now now seriously they used to be
the case and now it's like it's gone and
he's probably at the center of it but
it's become this idea of not self-help
it says really just like this idea that
we're all on a journey of lifelong
learning and we all are done biessing
ourselves and there's not a single
person that has all of life figured out
so why don't we all actively openly work
on this together
and I think it's awesome yeah and I
should also say that at one point as an
example I was interviewed on the BBC
and they wanted to talk about sell this
self-help genre and I knew it was gonna
be a setup right I knew that they wanted
me to defend self-help and they wanted
to attack self-help Hey so and I knew
this going in that this is what it was
gonna be or I figured it out about an
hour beforehand when I got some notes
and I was like oh I see where this is
going so they they bring me out this is
it this is a television show and they
say good evening mr. Farris we just
wanted to talk about that uh bio bio
blah blah blah what is your general
opinion of the self-help genre or
something along these lines
and in effect I said I think 99.9% of it
is just horseshit and I said it's it
pains me sometimes to be associated with
the label self-help for x y&z reasons
and then that they didn't have a leg to
stand on right because I'd taken their
side of the argument which was kind of
hilarious and and then I said but at the
same time I think the label self-help
has in many cases an unfairly negative
connotation because a if you look at
almost any type of reading whether it's
a novel where people want to escape or
it's nonfiction or they're hoping to
learn more about let's just call it
Andrew Carnegie or you name the figure
there's there is some motive behind that
that they hope to help them whether it's
a shift of emotion the gathering of
knowledge they can impress people at a
dinner party or otherwise and that if I
were to look at who I would say
potentially emulate in the world of
self-help it would probably be someone
like this is the name you brought up
earlier Ben Franklin right and you most
certainly wrote extensively about what
we would consider today self-help but
he's not lumped into the category of say
potential and these people do exist
certainly charlatans who are just
selling a bill of goods that doesn't
deliver right there are plenty of people
who have not walked the walk and talked
extensively about their expertise and
make recommendations and prescriptions
there are people all over the world in
every possible discipline who do this
and a lot of them tend to concentrate in
this section of the bookstore called
self-help unfortunately but it's it's
that alone isn't enough to disqualify
something and certainly if we look at
these the popularity of tutorials on
YouTube for instance of in any possible
subject matter if you look at the
popularity of the creative lives and the
course errors and so on sure everyone
now has access to expertise that even
ten years ago would have cost hundreds
of thousands of dollars to access if
they had the ability at all you look at
say Harvard MIT Stanford many of these
schools that are putting their courses
online in some cases for free access and
I know people who have taught themselves
to code in this way all of that is self
help right yeah so it's it's important I
think that people not disqualify
exploring certain realms because of a
label that really represents a concept
which may or may not apply to what it is
you're examining yeah I mean there's
gonna be scammers in every genre - yeah
i love i love how chill rogen i'm if you
seen these posts that he's done recently
but he does videos of these marques
legit is [ __ ] yeah yeah that's he with
their mind yeah you think you're Rogen
puts up these fake martial arts videos I
mean they're not fake they're videos of
people who actually believe that what's
happening is happening but yeah these
these like martial arts masters
self-described
throwing people across the room with
their Chi explosions and so on and his
caption is usually legit as [ __ ] or hash
tag that [ __ ] is so good yeah there's a
lot of nonsense out there but it doesn't
mean that everything within a certain
category is nonsense yeah and it doesn't
mean you should spend your entire life
filtering for the 1% but also there are
ways that you can assess the validity of
different paths and quite frankly I
would recommend for those people who
haven't well I'll give you two
recommendations so one is you can look
at the back of the 4-hour body if you
already have it there's an appendix
which is effectively how to spot bad
science and it will help you to not
trick yourself and also to get
better at avoiding being tricked so
that's that's one recommendation and and
not to seem like I'm selling my own book
the excerpts for that appendix are from
a book called bad science by a doctor
named Ben Goldacre which is absolutely
fantastic so if you just want to be
literate and better able scientifically
literate or better able to separate the
signal from the noise with the deluge of
information that we are assaulted by
everyday I would highly recommend that
you check out one or two one or both of
those resources you know I was gonna ask
you
tools of Titan's I mean obviously in
yearbooks there have been tons of book
recommendations yeah and there was that
one kid do you remember the kid that I
took all and he'd created he still got
all the books out of your eruptions and
ranked him ranked him or just organized
them as thumbnails yeah I do remember
that yeah so the idea was that what is
the most recommended book inside tools
of titans across the board yeah all the
people that were that were in that book
and kind of stack ranking them based on
the votes do you have that list anywhere
do you have a list of like the most
recommended books by all of your guests
yeah I do actually and I'll pull it I'll
pull it up right now because I put it I
put it on the blog for everybody it's a
great way yeah I put it up yeah there's
a great way to cut through all the crap
you know yeah I put it up on the blog
and if you give me a second I will find
where it is this might take a second so
I'm looking at tribal mentors the most
recent but the Justice where would I
find this if you go on to tim dot blog
and search like tools of titans books we
can put a link in the show notes right
put a link in the show notes so if you
want a link this will be the smarter way
to do it if you want to see a page where
the most commonly recommended books from
tools of titans and from tribal mentor
so the combined you're looking at about
500 different world-class performers of
all different disciplines ranging from
top professional athletes to chess
prodigies to former generals certainly
12 plus billionaires then you will get
to
see rank-ordered in terms of frequency
which books are most recommended so I
will put those in the show notes and you
guys can find that at Tim da blog
forward slash podcast if you want to see
you know of these people who are the
best at what they do which books across
disciplines do they recommend most often
a few of them just off the bat for
people who are curious a man's search
for meaning by Viktor Frankl poor
Charlie's Almanac by Charlie Munger
seeking wisdom by Peter Bevan and
certainly Atlas Shrugged even though
it's a controversial book but iron Rand
comes up a lot in terms of developing a
sense of personal agency I think that
has popped up quite a lot and many more
but I'll give you the full list because
there are some that pop up quite
frequently that you won't recognize at
all and those are to me oftentimes the
the really fun wants to explore awesome
yeah I've got a bunch of audible credits
waiting to be spent so I'll do that
awesome man well I think that this is
this is a solid catch up yeah thanks for
having me on and it was fun to chat and
we're working people learn more about
Kevin Rose find you yeah interwebs
certainly my podcast is available at
Kevin Rose calm and then also if you
want to check out my free meditation app
it's a hundred percent free little bit
more traditional meditation it's called
oak and you can do that at oak
meditation calm nice and succinct no
social well I don't you know Twitter at
Kevin Rose but like I don't know that I
use it that much anymore I'm more a
newsletter guy if you go to my website
if you sign up for my newsletter I do a
once a month newsletter and that's
that's kind of what I use it's a good
newsletter I subscribe to it which I
can't say for many and yeah Twitter's
Twitter's turned into a bit of a nasty
neighborhood on most days you just feel
ya minding your business whistling
walking down the street then you have
people throwing potted plants at your
head and then Facebook's a whole [ __ ]
show so it's like that's the worst kind
of show what to do go back to the tried
and true Instagram Instagram or email
yeah all right my man well so much for
taking the time
and hope to see you soon yeah come come
visit Austin God well got a barrel sauna
waiting for you awesome
alright man see ya see everybody
listening or watching on the youtubes
you can find links to everything that
we've talked about in the show notes
Tim dog forward-slash podcast and until
next time be safe
do not take meth for fun follow
professional advice with anything
medically related and live the examined
life just because it is self-help
doesn't mean it can't help you so I will
leave with that
you